pour moi c'était très important parce
que nous avons tous été très émouvant de
revenir c'est vraiment un rendez vous
d'un mot mais devant tant d'amour que
devant alors je sais pas parce qu'on
vient tout petit petit j'avoue fermeté
les adieux vous savez j'aime assez
réduit j'ai dit que je prenais j'ai
jamais fait d'études jamais ça c'est ce
que c'est ce que c'est plus ou moins ce
que la presse a dit ne mange jamais
paraître j'ai dit que je prenais des
distances et j'ai pris des distances
parce que cet amour l'homme était très
importante elle ment important m'importe
c'est tellement que je voulais
d'instruction mais j'ai pris dix points
après six longs métrages en plus apte à
la java 12 15 chansons nouvelles c'est
pas tout à fait le cas et j'ai pas le
cas parce que j'ai pas écrit et en fait
je sais pas si c'est important de venir
s'il faut absolument être nouveau vous
faire dire en tout cas ce qui me
concerne j'ai pas écrit donc j'ai pas
fait sans mal écrire ce que j'ai pas pu
écrire
et justement ce qui est fantastique
c'est que c'est bon j'ai l'impression
que mes chansons n'ont pas sans
nouvelles mais que je les chante pour la
première fois ça c'est vrai et ce qui
est fou c'est que il n'attend pas de
chansons nouvelles finalement c'est ça
que tel qu est ce qui est inexplicable
parce que je comprends pas ça prévient
si l'om ne me revient
lors de mon commandant du plus loin du
premier rang vous tuent tant de
premières peines lors j'avais 15 ans
surtout blanc et gris faisant genou
ce fut j'étais fréquence de tendance au
monde quand on est mort sur un amour fou
plus loin ils m'ont soutenu si depuis
j'ai je t'aime ma plus belle histoire
d'amour fou ce vrai jeu d'enfant
j'ai tout pour bien des familles pour
les lire blanche depuis rien
c'est vrai je ne fus pas un jouet meggen
et demain
déjà disparu
m robert leur visage et vous déjà venu
je refais est du bas rhin pour suivre
mon virage plus belles histoires de
moscou
sur la longueur où tu me l'avais
sur la longueur jallet
le vent de l'est sans que les thons
rouges
l'impensé du site est pour vous le fait
que la route mais je me laisse de marbre
jusqu'à four
je ne suis pas par jour si ce soir j
pour vous un janot il en eût fallu bien
d'autres tous quelques mauvaises aux
poudres
l'hiver où la neige à menton pour ce que
je trouve les patients et j'écrivais
violence je fais l'histoire
en hiver et d'entendre deux nuits de fou
métier jamais son rang
elle vous peut donc en dessous d'un
trailer
j'avais besoin de vous le dire mais nous
aurons d'autres montrent ouverts le
panda heureuse je m'envole est loin de
oui je vous faisais fidèles en même mais
belle histoire d'amour pleurait mais non
il me fut tout sauf à me sentir de
pour une alarme qui venait leur aidé à
m'en souvenais foot un sport où vous
étiez venus l'attendre ici même vous en
trouvez vous
à mort par des sourires
à vous aimer sans regarder la peuge
écran et un tabou
le fils et mon voyage
si tu es venu au rendez-vous que bon
c'est qu'on peu tendu je tenais à vous
dire ce soir je vous remercie de vous
prouve qu'on dit qu'on veut je pouvais
le dire sur l'histoire d'amour vous